bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got alex
here with me what's up man what's going
on here we're doing it in miami
yes we are all right what the hell is
zed z.run has like taken over the world
it's digital horse racing
yeah so i got into it about a month and
a half ago
all right that scares everyone
immediately when it's only six weeks but
that's certain context
yeah i got into about a month and a half
ago almost two months ago
uh some like backstory i have a friend
drew
drew austin he's a great guy he runs a
thing called redbeard ventures
and um he tried to get me into nba top
shot
in like early well and try to get me
into nba top shot
like october november december time of
this past year and that was 20 20.
yeah and that was really early that
would have been a good time to get an
nba top shot all right and then he was
in miami actually at the end of the year
beginning of
beginning of january end of december and
we were sitting down at some hotel
and he was like showing me he's like i
just spent like 1500 bucks
and i bought this like zion williamson
cosmic hollow
like one out of 50. i'm like dude what
are you doing like
why are you spending you just flushed
1500 bucks down the toilet
and he's like no i bought like a john
moran i bought this like vince carter
last shot all these like cosmic hollows
whatever
i was like what's going on he's like
just buy a pack
experience it took me about a week to
buy a pack
and when i did i was like oh this is
really cool like the opening of it
and uh anyway flash forward about a
month later his portfolio
is worth about over two million dollars
on a
fifty thousand dollar investment that's
pretty good i'm no mathematician but
that's pretty good
it's pretty good uh and that that was a
really expensive week because that week
i could have bought like a few
like legendary packs for like you know
200 bucks
which anything you got there is worth
you know 3k
plus um and i was like ah okay i got to
listen to drew next time
drew and i started this like weekly
event and there's there's context to
this backstory but
drew and i started this like weekly
event uh on the company everyone called
upstream
uh we have an nft community we meet
every friday at 1pm
and every week we talk about something
different so the first week we talked
about top shot
the second week i think we talked about
genies then the week after we had like
akash who's the founder of genies
they were launching some nft stuff and
then on wednesday i was like hey drew
who should we have this this weekend
he's like
oh i'm getting into this thing called
zed um
i'm actually buying a bunch of horses
for some friends do you want me to buy
you a horse
or a few horses and i was like dude what
are you talking about like digital
horses it's not real
well first i was like i don't need a
horse like and he's like no it's digital
horses you race them you breed them
he's like i don't have time to explain
right now but let me know if you want me
to buy you some horses and i was like
all right i didn't listen to you last
time like how much each do i need to
send you
to get like a nice whatever whatever
you're doing so i sent him a little bit
of money
um how much uh i think it's in like
5k and heath okay and then and then
on friday we started talking about this
thing called zed
um which was that for one horse no he
got me like a few
this was still early so it wasn't super
expensive yet uh
so you're like you're like a horse
empire no he got me like five horses it
was like a few z
one z three z four z five and a few z
like nines and tens
um which i'll explain all what that
means in a minute um
and what what he ended up doing is on
friday we started talking about it
and i was like oh wait drew is this the
thing you bought me earlier this week
and it's like yeah
i was like oh this is actually really
cool uh anyway
that night was a was a drop and they
released like 200 horses
and drew had said you know a month
before that event we did uh it took
about like 12 hours
or like 24 hours to sell out the horses
and then the next week because they were
doing drops every friday
the next week it took like it was cut in
half it was like 12 hours or six hours
then it was like six hours or three
hours after we did that event on
upstream and after after
because it was like 50 to 100 people
there they sold out the horses in about
10 minutes
and then from there on you can barely
get a horse in the drop i mean it's
really hard
um so in terms of that's how i got into
it okay um
and i bought a bunch of horses that
night i i have
at least 27 horses myself
my dad's got nine i share a stable with
drew we have another seven
we've got like one or two like pretty
rare coats and
uh early mints and then i share another
staple with a friend named narendra
and he uh he built this whole algorithm
to figure out like
rare and super rare coats um so yeah
it's
so you own like 50 horses about like i i
own and co-own about 50 horses
all right but in terms of what what zed
is i mean it's digital horse racing so
the idea is what i say that like it's
like
normal normal thing but uh yeah it's
you know i i personally believe like 90
of nfts are going to be worthless i
think the things that
are going to stay are going to be things
with strong ip so
things like you know the nba top shot
mlb
ufc nfl eventually someone will do you
know soccer is going to be massive when
it comes out
because that has that's ip i think when
you know movies like
uh everything from star wars to marvel
to disney they have strong ip
well so my whole thing isn't so much
just the ip like the ip's important
obviously yeah but uh the one that like
i saw and i was like oh wow this is
really cool
is uh there's something called so rare
oh yeah which uh benchmark recently
invested in
and uh what they essentially did was
it's like fantasy football
for soccer or uh football as people
abroad will call it
and uh you basically don't get to just
draft players and then play like you do
you know like yahoo fantasy football or
whatever
instead you basically have to buy and
then you have the token and you can
trade and you can use certain players
and all stuff and so
to me it's not so much just like buying
this thing holding it and speculating
that the price is going to go up
the utility of the only way to play the
game is to have so that's the other
thing that's exactly
exactly so like ip's important and then
the other thing that's going to last
well
i think there's actually three things
that are less it's ip i think utility so
just buying it and selling it that's
great but if you can make money
if you can earn some sort of benefit
like a return or a yield
field or access to a location uh digital
or physical
if there's some sort of utility to it i
think those things are going to be
interesting and last
and then the last i think is the art
world i think you know
crypto art digital art you know it's
it's just a mimic of
physical i don't personally get a lot of
art but i know that there's a marker for
that
the scarcity the rarity etc i think the
cash grabs are gonna go away
i think the people that don't uh take
you know
time to figure out exactly what makes
sense i think i mean this past week was
a
crazy week for nfts i mean there was
everything from
i don't know if you saw appiman uh which
is like a
you're gonna think it's even more crazy
but it's like it's like an egg that you
can open so there's like 6 000 of them
and in the egg there's like this
creature and some of them are going to
be rare some of them are going to be
like diamonds like dinosaurs like yeah
exactly like little
like it's sort of like lol surprise i
don't know if you know a little surprise
you don't have
no young children no they did 9 billion
in revenue last year what is lol
surprise it's literally a
if you have a young daughter you
probably have seen it it's
it's um it's a toy and then you get an
egg and then you open the egg and in the
egg is a surprise
and it's one of the characters and
there's some rare ones there's some
common ones got it uh they did nine
billion revenue last year it's a
physical toy company
if you go to any like cvs walgreens and
you go to the toy section you'll see ll
surprise everywhere
okay um and so now there's a digital
version so yeah this thing called
appimon
then there's this thing called um uh the
board
yacht club that launched what is that
and it's like you get
you buy like this you get a yacht no you
get like an ape
and the ape is like we don't need to get
into the specifics but like
that you know that all this sounds crazy
this sounds insane okay uh
but the thing that's really interesting
about board uh board ape
yacht club is that they're giving you
if you own an ape you can get access to
a virtual place okay this yacht club and
only other people who own apes can come
so you think about okay if you own a
token or you own this nft
you can theoretically get access to a
digital place or a physical place that
nobody else can go to unless you're
a token owner or an nft owner i just
think that that gets to be really
interesting
these things all launched like this week
but at the same time
they're they seem to be very thoughtful
well designed and
been in the works for a while but but
back to zed so zed is horse racing zed
is horse racing digitally digital horse
racing and so when you go into the
system you can buy a horse
uh you can buy a horse during a drop
okay and then you can also buy it on
i think open c okay and then also how
many total horses are there
so we don't know yet yeah no we we do
know but
there's it's it's it's important to to
understand actually how it works so
right now we're still in the mid so it's
actually still really early for zed
there's going to be 38 000 genesis
horses
the rumor is they'll probably go through
the genesis horses by the end of the
summer maybe
the end of the year um i think there's
only 13 000 of those 30
37 38 000 that have been released
there's a rumor that this friday
um there's gonna be a uh i mean it's not
a rumor it's gonna be this friday
there's something called a terror drop
there's either gonna be five thousand or
seven thousand or ten thousand horses
that are going to be available directly
all at that time all at one time trying
to buy one
yeah you should okay i think you need to
own ethan right i think you're
you've been on the on the record of not
owning any i don't know
i can gift you your first horse if you
want i can make you but i only want the
best like i want the winner like i want
the secretarian of uh of all the horses
uh yeah well then you have is that the
name of the the horse that won this
thing
i think it's secretariat secretariat
yeah yeah i'm basically
a horse there's sea biscuit there's
secretary there's american flag biscuit
is a good one
american pharaoh was the most recent one
that went okay so american pharaoh i
want the equivalent of american pharaoh
in uh
zed how do i get that uh how much would
it cost me
how much would it cost you i mean i i've
heard that
i think like is there one horse
everybody's like that's the winner yeah
there's like there's breathless edge
there's ducky malin
there's these hor these horses are
becoming a little famous because they're
such a winnerless edge
breathless edge is one ducky undefeated
one no but like a 30
win rate i want an undefeated one
there's no undefeated actually there was
the reason why breeding is not available
right now is because
when they brought breeding back there
was a
it wasn't i don't know if it was a bug
but some horses got four
parent dna i didn't get into breeding
yet but i'll get into that in a second
and these horses were like freaks of
nature i think there's one called
escobar
yeah i want escobar there you go
freaking nature named escobar that's the
horse
who owns that one i don't know but it
was the first 10 races the horse was
10-0
and people and but it was like winning
you get odds and stuff and it was
winning by like
like like like multiple seconds
escobar sounds like a champion that's
what i do yeah i think that when they
bring it back they're gonna look they've
changed some things and it'll be fixed
are they gonna like take away escobar's
skills
no i i i don't know 100 know how it
works but i think that they
the things they take into account
they're going to have to change stuff
because you can't change
escobar's abilities because it's on the
blockchain
so you have to sort of i'm not 100 sure
how it works how they're going to change
the odds
they're going to rig the game because
that's the bars it's going to be the
same
yes but no they're going to be they're
going to have to level it up so that
everyone
has like that that same situation got it
but anyway so so going back to
38 000 genesis horses these are minted
by zed and they are
there's there's ten levels so there's z1
to z10
z standing for zed z1 to z10 z1
is the most uh scarce z10 is the
most scarce uh the least scarce um
z1 is called nakamoto
after it's good this good name satoshi
so that's z1 and z2 are both nakamotos
there's a thousand z1 nakamotos there's
a thousand z2 nakamotos
in the last drop a z1 nakamoto uh
was selling directly from zed not like a
resale value directly from zed for about
16 000
horse okay z
three and four are called zabo named
after i think
nick nick zabo uh there's two thousand z
threes two thousand z fours then there's
the five
six and seven are finney after how
finney
and then eight nine and ten is butyrate
or butter in or
you know metal metallic z10 i think
there's going to be about
20 000 and i may be getting the number
off a little bit but i think there's
about gonna be about 20
000 z10 buterins okay so that's gonna be
the most common
in the last drop i think computer and
went for about 100 120
um and those are the most common you'll
see now
okay so that's 38 000 genesis horses
there will never be more
genesis horses and they're still
releasing them which means it's still
still early and then they all go have
sex with each other
yeah it's called digitally it's called
the stud farm and the stud form yeah
it's called
explain okay so then then there's
breeding i need to get in the horse
game yeah no it's it's what it actually
so there's male and female horses
there's
uh the un un when you don't have any
offspring
um it's a philly for a female
and then a cult for a male okay and then
once you have a child you're a mayor for
a female and then you're a
stallion for a male okay now there's a
stud farm
the other thing that's actually worth
noting is there's there's also
um there's also coats
so there's uh common coats like the
color of their
their coat then there's rare and then
there's
uh like super rare or something like
that um
so there are some really like what does
escobar have
it's got to be rare i wanted to i want
to say i think
it was like fire brick i could be
getting that
red i think it was a rare or a super
rare i'm not sure you got a red horse
that was just
cleaning the competition yeah yeah it
was i think i i i should go buy escobar
before we release this before somebody
jacks up the price on me if i want to go
buy it
go ahead well i think escobar came down
to earth in terms of the
value so and yeah i mean value also but
by the way most of these people who own
these like really like champion horses
there's really no reason for them to
sell it to you why because they can make
money without selling it to you
yeah but it's i mean it's kind of so
like cash flow right for example just
buy them out the second horse ever
minted was called a horse called wall
street it's also a pretty good horse has
like a 20
win rate or like between 15 and 20 is
pretty solid
wall street can put itself in the stud
form
and charge a thousand dollars to breed
with wall street
and people will pay a thousand dollars
to get an offspring of wall street how
much sex can the horse have
so that that's a great question um so
because i actually
i recently looked at my brother was
telling me the amount of
uh breeding that a champion horse like a
kentucky derby
champion horse between 100 and 250 times
a year
and then they also fly them around the
world with physical horses
uh because they have to be in warm
weather i think so they basically go
from hemisphere to hemisphere
to make sure that it can get extra
breeding on a annual basis
that's crazy but that's actually
randomly similar to how actually uh
it works okay so um when
the stud farm is currently closed it's
going to be hopefully opened up i think
they're waiting for the drop to happen
and then they're gonna
are they like closing it because this is
still kind of like a beta no they closed
it because there was the bug there was
like the
people were reading these free courses
and like escobar yeah escobar and there
was another there's like one or two more
by the way this is like the most crypto
thing in the world i'm hearing about
horses named wall street and escobar
basically the same two types of people
they're both organizations
go ahead yeah but by the way so actually
the zed
genesis horses are named by the
employees of zed okay
and then the offspring is named by the
users whoever so like if i
like make a baby for you then you can
name it
if you wanted to if somebody just hears
that clip they're going to think we're
crazy yeah
all right okay so if i put wall street
okay
so how the stud farm works you put males
into the stud farm yeah okay
so you put the male horses in every two
weeks
they can have seven offspring okay so
you as the owner of that male
horse you put it in there and you
dictate how much it costs to
to mate with your horse so if you have a
z1 nakamoto named wall street
you might charge a thousand bucks to to
breed with it
just because you probably can get seven
horses
you know seven no i mean so i
one night i just wanted to experience it
i put i just wanted to experience the
stuff
um i put i put i have a z1 i put one
oh you got like one of the big dogs i
have one i've i've three z ones now
three z ones all right how much did you
how much do they cost you uh
i uh about 10 to 12 k
each okay and then so let's say thirty
thousand dollars you're in on the z ones
yeah and you put them in the stud form
all of them so well actually so i own
three myself
and then i share two with drew so i have
a few
honestly i've i put some money into this
i think sounds like it but i've also so
i put
are we making money or losing money then
well i mean obviously i put out money
but
for an example i put my z1 into the stub
farm
and uh within 12 hours i i charged
600 to mate with it 500 or 600 i just
wanted to see if it would go
but i went and i did this at like
midnight i went to bed woke up i had
3k in my my oh people were trying to
mate
i was all mated it was all seven it was
done that that that
meaning i made three grand off a horse i
bought for like 10 grand
you made three granddaughters a horse
having sex with another digital horse
with multiple digital horses yes yeah i
did
this is why i'm fascinated by this
because it feels like it's a recreation
of exactly what happened in the analog
world
and it's going to happen again in the
digital world and there is the
opportunity to be the greatest horseman
in the world yeah by the way the other
thing is i have a horse called winter
winter wonderland okay
it's a rare coat did you name that no
that was it was a it was a genesis horse
um winter wonderland has
uh is a z4 z5 okay
and it's a it's a rare coat sir
aquamarine
and i put it in the stud farm also and
winter wonderland has raced in one match
and it won that match so it is a hundred
percent win rate
okay and you sound like you sound like
the finance kids on tick tock that are
like i have one stock
and the stock went up go ahead but no i
i
i 100 percent raising it i stopped i
mean like you're not gonna get better
than a hundred percent
like okay you know okay that's only one
for one
i put in the stud farm also seven horses
12 hours it was all gone i put it for
like 200 each because
it's not a z1 so i put it for 200 each
me like done me like
a grand easy and i didn't even spend a
grand to
buy it or maybe i did i don't know i
that was one of the ones drew got me
originally
um so seven seven offspring
only raced once i look at i i went back
you get a cut on the yeah and so does
that uh no not on the offspring i get a
cut
to breed yeah so that the person who has
the female horse
pays you pays um who owns the baby horse
the female ah got it so is it better to
have the male or the female
you can make more money instantly by
male but female i mean you could resell
the the children
yeah sounded really bad
this sounds you you could you could you
could resell the offspring
yeah so here's my question so the reason
well the last thing
the reason that i brought that up is one
of the children
is a champion horse so i looked through
because you you could see all the
lineages
yeah i look there's a there's a i think
it's called night queen
and it's like a champion horace it's got
like 40 plus wins
and then whoever bred it has just been
racing it
and it's a good horse see because that
doesn't mean your horse is good
probably because you don't want to race
it because then i don't want to raise it
because
i won 100 i think i could just get an
annuity of like a thousand bucks every
two weeks just from that like
not even thinking about it 24 grand a
year so
that's math you see that public math
that's pretty good that's pretty good
um but that that uh that the z1 that i
have
is not raced so you don't know like so
that well so you got to see
one but you never raced it i never
raised it and that's what people people
think it's a good one
well it's sort of like getting imagine
you can get an unopened you know
nba top shot pack right and it's a
cosmic hollow
series one so you can get a lebron you
can get a zion in there
but you also can get like even though
they're still i mean if you're a
basketball player yeah you're good but
like you can get like a cd osman and a
lengths and galloway
great you know good players serviceable
players but not they're not lebron or
zion
so so if you have a z1 and then it loses
its first two races
then you don't you don't want that
that's worthless immediately
lowers the value but if you see that the
offspring are good
then the value can all right go so i i
gotta give you a piece of context here
because i've been sandbagging
so uh the reason why i'm so fascinated
by this is in 2016 i believe it was
i went to nigeria and in nigeria uh
i went with uh somebody who's building
like a um uh
chat app for soccer and uh we had a like
local who was a user of that app take us
around and i'm when i say when i went to
nigeria most people go and they say
victoria island which is like where all
the tourists stay
we stayed in lagos like there's dudes
with ak-47
standing outside the hotel and like it
looks like it's secure but if somebody
starts shooting they're definitely
running
so so you're like in lagos right uh and
it was
about i don't know uh a mile from a
place called computer village in nigeria
and computer village is uh think of like
the busiest you've ever seen times
square
exactly like that and it is just packed
almost like a like a flea market would
be
there's stalls and stores and all stuff
and in some of the places it's two or
three stories
and it's just people everywhere and
what's fascinating about it is they are
so in touch with technology it's
probably i literally wrote a piece when
i came back and i was like i saw the
future of consumer
technology by looking uh in this one
little place called computer village
demographics of nigeria off the chart
population growth incredibly fast
uh very very digital native and then
they've now got smartphones internet
access all stuff
so while we're there with some time to
burn and the local
takes us to a equivalent of like i'll
call it a betting house i don't know
what they call it
and while we were there we had like
watched uh soccer games in people's
backyards and like done all this stuff
and like
there's a whole little economy around uh
soccer and viewing but we go to this bet
house
and literally uh think of it almost like
the cage at a casino so people are
sitting in chairs
they're watching games on television
they get up they walk over they place
their pet they get a little piece of
paper they go sit back down
did i win did i lose go back and they're
doing this all day long right
but then all of a sudden i noticed that
everyone
at all times was watching one of the
screens on the far right
what's going on on that screen why does
that one not have commercials what's
going on over there
and that was also the one that i quickly
realized was having the most betting
activity
it was a simulation it was like you know
we play video games yeah and like you're
playing like a soccer game or a football
game or whatever and you just hit
simulate and the game basically plays
the game
and then it just tells you like oh the
green bay packers won right yes never
really happens in real life the giants
are the best team
uh and so i remember sitting there being
like
these people are betting on a simulation
in a video game
that's nuts because as an american guess
what my first thing is
it's rigged there's no way it's fair
right
like somehow it is raped but they were
betting
all day every day so when i saw that i
remember just putting them in the back
of my head like that's an interesting
thing
one about my dad when i saw the digital
horse racing that's the first thing i
thought of i said oh my god somebody
figured out how to do this
have no clues it rigged it's not rigged
doesn't work does not work whatever but
somebody figured out how to take that
exact same
experience and now bring it to a global
basis and it's around horse racing
and that seems pretty interesting to me
so
it feels like the only three things you
can really do are one you can buy a
horse
you can race it you can buy a horse you
can
put it in the stud farm read it or you
can basically create more horses and
then go race those horses
fair uh yeah and by the way seven male
horses every two weeks
when you breed two uh
every female horse can have two
offspring
every two weeks okay so meaning when you
originally said
like they could do 150 if you do the
math seven every two weeks
14 a month you're getting pretty close
to the actual yeah and maybe that's how
they actually
100 to 250 is the uh is the number so
it's like 100 on average
versus uh i think it was uh 250 if they
move them all around the world
you know different hemispheres yeah so
in terms of
in terms of um breeding you know only
two from the female
which i don't know if that's real life
like i don't know how like
i don't know what the pregnancy of women
uh female horses are yeah
yeah off the top of my head neither do i
um i don't think they're one week at a
time though
yeah but uh but in but in terms of yeah
so i mean
breeding so it's buying and holding
breeding uh and um
and like making money off that so i've
i've made someone have that
and then racing now how does the racing
work and how do you know it's not rigged
so there's a bunch of white papers that
i've read like a few sentences of
uh and there's a bunch of there's an
article they wrote about like
it's called like provably fair now the
way that they describe it is there's 10
000 simulations
of each race and they there's one that's
chosen at random to be that race so when
you go up against
11 other horses because there's 12
horses one of those
uh like everyone has odds so so if i
if i have the odds of winning 20 out of
100 times you just extrapolate that out
to 10 000 simulations
and then basically that's the odds and
then they run each simulation
and then they literally just pick okay
simulation seven thousand four hundred
and thirty two is the one everyone's
gonna see and that's somehow randomly
selected
and when that occurs based on the odds
that my horse has of winning out of
every hundred or a thousand or ten
thousand races then that's the odds for
that specific race
yeah um exactly that's how i understand
it
um that seems complex enough where like
that would be pretty hard to gain
yes the thing is that every horse
so every horse the way i've
i've come to understand it is every
horse is like uh
minted with like a base number and the
only thing that right now is taken into
account
is distance preference so
it doesn't matter what gate they are in
it does not matter
what time of day it doesn't matter how
many races that they've had there's no
fatigue
the horses currently live forever
there's so there's no
like there's no like the horse is
getting old right now the only thing
that gets taken into account is distance
preference
so there's a thousand meter races all
the way up to 2
600 meter races and you have to
if that's why i haven't raced into my z
my z ones is because
if i erase it i need to dedicate time to
figure out if it's any good at anything
and then when i know what it's good at
or if well by the way some of these
horses are donkeys like you
you don't want to go races how much
money can i win racing
i've seen horses that have that have
made uh
close to six figures already with just
one race
no oh uh oh the biggest actually no the
so that it used to be like five dollar
entry up to 50
entry but now there's like i think i saw
like a
5 000 entry so it's going up the most
i've one in a race is like 200 bucks
200 bucks all right so far but that was
when it was only 250. so it sounds like
it's way better have the
horses have digital sex than to raise
the horses currently so the my
thesis around this and a lot of people
think is that the genesis game
of zed is around breeding so find the
good horses and then
breed them you know and by the way you
you take someone like a breathless edge
if breath is edge
i don't know if breath such as a male or
female but imagine it's a male
and goes into the stud farm that person
could charge you know five grand per
horse 10 grand pours and they will sell
all seven of them
no question because it's that good of a
horse when you're placing fifty percent
of the time and you're winning thirty
percent of the time
like you know or ducky malin which is
another one like
they're gonna char they're going to be
able to command a premium
so that's why the way you think about
the breeding so i think the breeding
part
well i think the genesis horses is a
breeding game and i think the offspring
is a racing game
so i think like the best horse is gonna
because
because
there's genesis horses when you breed
two genesis horses
you create a legendary horse okay when
you when you breed legendary horses you
create i think
either elite or exclusive and then
there's like two or three so there's
like all these things but genesis are
the best ones
genesis are the original ones they're
the the original ones minted
but does original mean best not
necessarily okay
i've seen z5s beat z1s and races just
because you're a z1 doesn't mean you're
100 gonna win
so because probability yeah but also
like i i have a horse
um that is really good at 1600 meter
races
so i get really good odds uh
dagnabbit dagnabbit did you name it no
okay no come on that's not that's not a
name
i don't know i i i read some horses for
my daughter okay uh she's five
she likes she likes does she like
watching the oh we watch the games
together she comes home from school she
wants to race it
so the original horse that i rate
when you when you breed nakamoto's
together you create another nakamoto
but if you do like a nakamoto and a zabo
it creates a zabo if you do nakamoto in
a
finney it creates a finney whatever the
lesser
like one is is what the offspring is
okay um
but i i brought her in nakamoto uh so
she is a z2 oh by the way when you do z1
and z1
you create a z2 if you do a z1 and a z5
you create a z6
got it okay um just simple math yeah
yeah it's just you have to add up
there's
a u2 z10 z20 c20 i think you go up to
like z
hundred two hundred something it was a
crazy crazy number
um but anyway so the
i've read her she has a z2 i think a z2
or z3
nakamoto she named it gemstone and then
it's great gemstones a girl so we had
two
two offspring uh sparkles and rainbows
both mentioned in the new york times
article and uh which i think your
daughter is five
she's five okay does your daughter go to
school and say i own three horses
she does tell people she owns horses uh
she's like she's like
it's like not my dad like i own the
horses yeah but she doesn't say like
it's a digital horse she says like i own
a horse
yeah for her it's different it's the
same yeah um but it's funny because
they're mentioned in the new york times
article that was just this past week on
zed
and someone mentioned to me he's like
good job getting the horse name in new
york times
if you go and you put it on discord or
if you put it in the
stud farm you'd be like you know
rainbows mentioned in the new york times
come breed with it or
you know you can like the value goes up
for horses that are like publicly
mentioned
i don't know if that's true why don't
the horses die
i i think they get tired i think they're
debating it yeah
but right now like i i've heard that
they're going to eventually add gate
preference
i've heard that they're going to
eventually add weather uh and i imagine
the lad fatigue
so you can't just go race because right
now you could essentially take your
horse i could take escobar
which i need to own and then i could
basically race escobar 20 times in a day
and it doesn't matter
so right now you can be in three races
at one time meaning
three like there's a bunch oh i don't
even do 20 in a day i could literally
like three races all at the same time
simultaneously
yes that's the most you can but they
don't have to be surtamously running but
the most you can enter is three horses
at a given time so once one of those
races ends you can enter another one
got it okay yeah so you could i mean
people
there are they're horse millionaires
they're degenerate people
sitting there all day raising their
horses but they're making money
sometimes sometimes you're losing money
yeah you have to i like the breeding
game the breeding game sounds a lot more
up mine
but the horse the the racing game there
is a bit of skill to it because you have
to figure out you can't just like
blindly erase it
you have to look at the data um you have
to figure out
okay when is this horse is this horse
doing really well like okay it's going
1400 meter races but it's not winning
um but it's in but it's in first place
when it when you hit a thousand meters
so
should i be you know only entering into
a thousand meter races
you have to figure out a lot of that
stuff but once once you start looking at
the data like there's a lot of like
sabermetrics type of data
once you start looking at the data it's
it's a game changer i
i had two horses that i knew were decent
but i didn't know how decent they were
and then i looked at the odds and
and like the detailed data and i was
like oh i have to race this only 1800
meters and above
and this one only 800 million below and
i'm gonna make i'm gonna actually make
money
um if you enter enough races for five
ten fifteen dollars can you race while
you're in the stud farm
uh no i i think you're not i think
you're not allowed to race while you're
in the sun farm yeah i mean that would
make sense you're
you can't be racing and and breeding
okay
uh if i'm thinking of this game
it feels like the people who own the
horses are a step below
the people who own zed right
but then there's this like middle ground
i want to own a track
how do i do that so i've heard so they
did a they announced a partnership with
atari
okay that atari is going to be doing
like branded
a few branded horses like atari horses
that are gonna be like rare
and then i've heard that there's like i
mean you could think about like the
central land and things like that where
why not why not buy a track and and be a
bookie
you know like zed won't be the bookie
zed won't be draftkings
zedd's the nba zed's the nfl we're
the owners we're we're we're mark cuban
you know we're we're the
we're the team owners and mark owns any
horses
i don't know i fear he'd say it yeah no
i don't think he owns any horses sorry
who owns the most horses
that's a great question funny story
which is sort of
uh about this i was i caught up with a
friend recently
and i was we were talking about like
crypto and zed and nfts
and he's like you know my um my my
sister married this guy
and he has been obsessed with zed for
like a few months
and like the family is about to have
this interface like he's just racing
digital horses all day
and the family's about to have it like
an intervention with him and i was like
send me the stable link like
send me like i want to see the stable
and um he sent it to me it's like
13 z ones like
and he co-owns the stable with a bunch
of people i'm like dude this guy has
like a multi-million dollar stable like
really do not intervene with it
like let him let him do his thing yeah
um so there's a bunch of those out there
there's a bunch of people who have
stocked up early you know i think
i think a few months ago a z1 was going
for like
5k not 16k
so you know you could it's a price
appreciation yeah so and
and each drop the it goes up about 20
in terms of like the the floor value uh
someone offered me 40k for one of my z
ones i said no i think i think that'll
be worth
once the genesis horses are done i think
z ones it's only a thousand of them
genesis z1s
i mean they're going to go for 100k each
minimum 100 on a million
100k 100 i think like the worst z1
will be worth 100k like you can barely
buy one for
you know 3040k right now wow
all right because there's not that many
so how do i own a track is that
available so no
currently not available uh i don't know
if it will ever be but it seems like
there is a lot
they want to do i mean i the way that
drew has always
described it to me was that like
they're building like the metaverse and
like horse racing is just like
the popular sport but like i don't know
why why don't why can't they do like dog
racing why can they do dragon racing
like they could do anything
so it's just like okay horses are like
why don't they do human racing
[Laughter]
we all put our avatars in there and just
have foot races
yeah i mean the question is you know can
you make these horses better
or do you or like are they are what is
there like a training process can i buy
a shitty horse and then like you know
like
so it's stronger you could theoretically
buy a shitty horse that was incorrectly
ran
so like if you see a horse that has
really bad odds at 2000 meters and the
owner was only running at 2000 meters
and then you start racing on others and
you realize oh this horse actually just
does really well at 1200 meters but you
don't know that until it runs those
horses yeah so you've got you so that
there's like a process to figure out
which is like you should probably
race the horse three to five times at
every single level at the cheapest way
you can
and then and then you okay look at the
data where am i getting good odds
it's also you get odds depending on who
you're going up against so if you go up
against escobar
and breathless edge and ducky milan like
you're gonna have pretty badass yeah
well esmar's undefeated
uh i don't know i don't know if that's
true anymore okay we can look it up
all right well i'm gonna own escobar and
it's gonna be undefeated
all right so uh what's the end game here
like are people just gonna
own the horses forever do they sell them
and like cash out like
i don't know listen if i can get uh if i
can get 2 3k
every two weeks from one horse
um no now maybe eventually like the
demand goes down but again z1's only a
thousand of them
you know uh nakamotos not many
nakamoto's in general
so if you can make that's the whole
utility thing if i can make money racing
and breeding
i'm not going to sell my horses why
would i sell them i'll make my all my
money back that i spent
just by doing those things and then let
just
continue to sort of and then grow it
from there so
do you reinvest or do you take the money
out i i'm currently it's all
just an eth just reinvested so i don't
reinvest it in ether and
more horses so like you have a an ether
count
in zed and then there's a w ether count
which i i don't know w stands for
wrapped
well yeah so that that's where you buy
that's where you could buy the horses
for you
all you ethereum people that's where you
can buy the horses
uh you can breed the horses and you can
um uh race the horses you have to use uh
w
uh uh eve so um
yeah i just it goes in there and i don't
like the funny thing is
this joke i've been saying with a bunch
of people is that like you go and you
race right
every night before i go to bed i just i
i know the odds i know which horse is
like i look for the right race
and i just put my horses in those races
and i go to bed and i wake up and i look
at if i want anything
the the funny thing is because eve has
been blown up
i put five dollars into a race i lose i
have 50 more dollars in my account
so it's like it's like it's really bad
for like degeneres
gamblers because like it's just going up
right now so because it's tied to it
yeah so
uh can you like outfit the horse
to look the way you want like not like a
saddle or anything there's no jockeys
there's no saddle
it's you you you have a coat that's
about it
but they're all 3d i don't know if
you've seen a race go but like it's
beautiful it's pretty cool and they got
like the cool camera angle
yeah it looks kind of futuristic a
little ready player one-esque right and
they're ready to rock and roll
yeah so i mean i i don't know where zed
100 is going
is it only ever going to be horses are
they going to do
other things but there's a lot of just
value and utility of just the horse
stuff
so i've been having fun um and like i
think
yeah you can make a lot of money off it
i think um
owning a track or or you know like like
z zed i don't think is ever going to get
into the gambling side of it
the draftkings and the and the fan duels
of the world
are going to go and and offer that the
bookies of the world
and like can you buy a track and then
charge get a fee for everyone who races
on your track
i think probably why not like what do
you
what do you do on a day-to-day basis we
sat here and we've talked about digital
horses tell us about the company
oh yeah no so i have a company called
upstream we're building like
you know linkedin groups 2.0 we're going
after professional networks
basically linkedin has had a monopoly
for the past like 18 years
and you know people like dunk on them
all the time linkedin sucks this that
i have a lot of respect for them i think
the core product is really strong the
digital resume
i mean there's a reason why you know
they have a monopoly it's it it's a
great product you know
i can look you up and see your past
history etc
but they've dropped the ball on a few
things uh the biggest i think
you know being who do you know and how
well do you know them
they killed their api a few years ago
for some good reasons but
i think there's a platform that could be
built on a professional network and then
what we're starting with is professional
groups
like nobody uses linkedin groups right
you know nobody actually even knows
linkedin groups is a thing i was just
gonna say don't even know what that is
yeah
exactly anyone who's building a
professional community is doing it on
slack they're doing it on whatsapp
they're doing on telegram doing on
discord
and i love all those products i use them
all they're just not really meant for
professional community
um so that's where we started and then
when covet hit
we you know like when you think of it's
like two pieces
top stream one is the professional and
like sorry the
the community and group side the other
is the professional side
in that professional side there's like a
life cycle meeting
new people socializing following up with
people reaching out to people
reconnecting with people that's all part
of like the professional life cycle
we're playing right now in the meeting
new people socializing
so we do this event uh we have this
product called upstream events
they're virtual events they're usually
20 to 30 minutes
we typically have a guest speaker the
first 10 15 minutes and then
the second half of it is matchmaking and
it's been really popular during covid
uh we've got you know um you know
thousands of people coming and meeting
each other every week
and it's just been it's been really
popular it's like that like during
covert is really hard to meet people
unless you're like
in miami um but uh yeah i know it's just
like you know
he he didn't say it but what he meant
was because miami was open everyone else
was closed
yeah i mean it was it yeah the joke is
like everyone in miami already had
coveted so
uh so that's why it could you know it's
a hurt immunity already here
no uh there's definitely some some good
stuff and bad stuff being here
we i moved my family i have a wife and
two daughters we moved down here in july
it's been really nice but anyway so this
company upstream
started it in the beginning of 2020
being my co-founder
before that i had a company called
social rank social media analytics
company
we sold it at the end of 2019. uh we
just started
upstream we uh we haven't announced yet
but we raised a little bit of money and
you know we've got a team of nine
awesome people and trying to build
the next professional network so you
basically you took your family
your company and your digital horses and
you moved to miami i bought the digital
horses down here but yes
i was born and raised in new york lived
there my whole life uh grew up on
manhattan
if you're successful with upstream what
does this turn into
right like in terms of is it literally
linkedin but a platform where people can
come and build on top of the social
graph
and it's all for professionals and
there's events and kind of like you just
like rebuild it for
the modern age or like today yeah so we
started on mobile so it was like a
mobile first
uh play but yeah no i what does success
mean i mean
building a professional network building
a platform so like
events are really cool and events are
really popular but it's just a piece of
the puzzle
and it's a it's a big piece like every
successful community should have events
virtual events in-person events etc um
but it's just a little piece of the
puzzle i mean you know i have a road map
for the next five 10 years in my brain
to be honest i want to do this rest of
my life i'm not uh
like you know we only met each other a
few months ago but we sort of
prioritized me
like this this is a big piece of it is
around giving and getting help
meeting new people professionally i love
that that's what i do every day
so if someone like a linkedin came along
and they're like hey we want you to run
linkedin groups and make it something
that people actually know what it is uh
i'd rather just do this i'd rather just
go out and raise more money and and try
to build a bigger company
though a lot of the the ways i think
about it is there's three pieces there's
live and synchronous which is like these
events then there's like asynchronous
which is like posting asks and
eventually they'll be more like
asynchronous
things on upstream and then the third is
utility so one of the things that we're
thinking about right now a lot
is like what type of utility can you
provide people maybe it's not directly
tied to community
but like who do you know and how well
you know them like how many times do
people hit you up and like
hey i saw that you're connected to this
person on linkedin like can you make an
intro and you're like i don't even know
who that person is like
i have to go look back figure out how i
met that person and there's a bunch of
really easy ways to figure that out
um a lot of people have gone after that
problem have gone about it in the
wrong ways they they try to build like
new address books so they try to build
like these
souped-up things that take like a week
for it to load and it just never really
works
the closest probably is like affinity
crm they've done a decent job at the
digital sort of um connection like who
do you know
frequency of connection but uh we're
working on some stuff now that hopefully
will be available in the summer
around like you know strength of
relationship and who you know how they
know that and i think that just balloons
into a much bigger opportunity
completely agree i think it's a smart
idea thanks man
all right i got three questions before i
let you go sure uh most important book
you've ever read
oh man most important book
i've been i've been i've been slacking
on the books i mean i i read this book
uh uh back in i wrote my college
i don't even remember what it was what
it was called but it was uh
it was like the seamstress i'm gonna
we're gonna have to edit this because
i'm not remembering the name of the book
i wrote my college essay about it but it
had a profound impact on me at the time
but the fact that i can't even remember
it i guess means something
yeah um let me think uh what's the
second question
let me think second question is sleep so
our friend's over at eight sleep
i got this bed uh it's freezing cold
right it's a thorough regulated bed
i sleep like five or six hours my wife
really wanted to like murder me
uh now i sleep like eight or nine hours
and it's been like the most
life-changing thing ever
um and hopefully they're gonna be able
to make it so you feel the same way
after
seven hours or six hours of sleep uh
what is your sleep schedule
it is two young kids yeah it is very bad
okay i need it i need like i do like
like how bad
it's over under five hours a night
around five
yeah all right but i so i that's like
borderline horrendous
yeah no i go to sleep but i wake up
i go to bed wait late but i wake up late
okay so i typically go to bed
between it'll be really nice i get to
bed at one
i usually go to bed two three oh wow so
like really like a night owl but then
yeah i do my best work between ten and
two i mean i you know okay
i feel like it's you know you're not
supposed to say that type of stuff
anymore like building companies but like
it's
truth like i just that's how i okay
that's how i function you know what time
do you wake up
usually eight nine all right so like
i trained my two daughters to wake up at
eight or later
that was the best time i ever did yeah
um so it's not that bad but
i know i need more sleep i usually catch
up on the weekends
got it all right third question aliens
are you a believer or a non-believer
i think statistically something has to
exist out there
you're like it's just like whenever if
you ever look at like where earth is
compared to the whole solar system and
galaxy i mean it's like just seems
just seems impossible that we're not
like that we're the only people
ever i don't know if anyone else is
still alive
i don't know if we can actually get to
them at the time like you know because
this might be too far away they may be
too far away but i think it's
probabilistically really low i think
what what
likely this chance is there's a lot of
other earths out there and they can't
see beyond their galaxy
yeah that's probably true and we can't
so we can't see them they can't see us
it's just too far away we sort of know
that there's a lot of stuff out there
but
we can't we don't have means of
communication uh you're gonna get asked
me one question to finish but uh my
favorite statistic
or uh data point on all of space is that
when i was in high school there was
nine planets including pluto now there's
over a
thousand yeah where did the rest of them
come from
like my only guess is that technology
got way better so that we can have
better
surveillance you know of the solar
system or whatever but like
that's a pretty big jump yeah no like
from nine to a thousand
yeah i i'm i
it seems unlikely that we're alone the
question is
if they get to us before we get to them
are we in trouble
you know so how do you know they haven't
been here
yeah i mean there's there's a there's a
pretty senior person from
i think it was either israel or ken or
whatever that you you probably if you
asked this question
the intergalactic federation i don't
know how you know that sounds a little
bit
for those that don't know there's a guy
i think it's from israel he uh was like
in charge of space or whatever yeah
like basically the equivalent with the
space force and he's like oh yeah we
all are in the intergalactic federation
and we just don't want to tell anyone
yet
yeah and like he's a little bit older
maybe a little he might he may be a
little going a little crazy
uh but then then he said some things
that were like well yeah why did trump
like
launch space force out of nowhere like
you know i mean that was like really a
random thing
like maybe there is something to it
maybe there is i don't know i don't i
don't know
and like i feel like
if there was like they would try to be
hidden but it's so hard to hide things
these days
yeah you know but like the ufo stuff has
been
crazy with like them releasing like we
don't know what this was we don't know
what that was
so like maybe i i i i
i'm not on the side of saying like no
yeah i'm same way but i'm not
on like i'd love to see it yeah you're
not on the like i met one
yeah but like you know that blink 182
guy like how like vindicated must he
feel like he stopped making music and
then like
went all in on aliens and like like he's
not wrong
yeah that's pretty cool by the way back
to the first question
i wouldn't say a book um i would say
the best thing that i've read is uh the
old mark andreessen posts
from from his blog i'm more of a blog
sort of
tweet reader uh but um
his his his old stuff still holds up
like just like just his thoughts on
building a company
and networks and all that stuff it's
just it's timeless i mean it's archive
somewhere
the the p market blog but that that's
probably the best thing i've read
um that's such a great suggestion yeah
all right
where can uh well first of all what
question do you have for me um so
something we ask every time on on
upstream when we have a guest speaker
we ask what do you need help with
usually there's like a handful of people
there and
we say like you could be hiring somebody
you could want to
we're going to hang a 65-inch screen
television but i got a guy coming today
but that's what i need help with right
now
because i'm scared that i'm going to
screw it up okay you need help with that
anything
anything you need help with that maybe
someone can help you uh
no send me the best investment deals
okay no that's a good one send the best
companies yeah
i mean that's like the easiest thing uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet
on twitter i'm at ajt how did you get
that
that's a whole other story so i had a
friend i'll i'll tell a quick version of
it all right i
have a friend at twitter she was leaving
um and
she uh she hit me up and she had it was
still
in back in the day when you could like
grab handles if you like it was inactive
so she's like i'm leaving my last day's
like next week make a list of handles
you want
and ah and send them to me and and just
have a handle i could swap it with
and if i can get it i'll get it um
that's not how i got ajt
i got it i got that from her early on
but
that haul i got uh i own truth on
twitter
i'm just sitting on it and i gave it to
the biting campaign a little bit
they played with it during the election
they got it up to like 250 000 followers
and then i thought i was getting it back
with 200 000 followers and then they
worked with twitter to wipe it and gave
me back with zero followers
i was like guys i gave it to you because
i thought i like come on
wow that was that was a big
disappointment i mean i didn't
ask them not to wipe it but like the
expectation was i was giving them to get
back a big account
um but i i i would understand how they
wouldn't want like let's say i became
crazy and i started posting like you
know
q and on stuff or whatever from at truth
yeah
yeah yeah i don't want to be associated
with that yep um
so i understand i was just upset i own a
bunch of random ones i
my daughters have at keira mm-hmm she's
her name's kira and then jd and her
name's jade so i have uh
i've got a bunch oh i have at nyk the
knicks are ny knicks
on ny winning record this year right
yeah i'm a little nervous we've got
eight games to go it looks good
but i'm just like i'm so fearful of like
a collapse
and like a eight-game losing streak out
of the playoffs
we haven't clinched yet or anything so
and it's hard teams i mean
going up against tonight denver then uh
uh phoenix uh clippers lakers
boston like that's not it's
i'm really happy how they're playing
but i'm just you know it would be it
wouldn't be nick thing it would be a
nick thing
games and just you know whoops yeah
yeah all right where can we some people
find you other than at ajt hey ajt
uh on upstream uh at upstream app.com
where you can download in the app store
where else am i on the internet um
linkedin
yeah you can by the way i have respect
for linkedin uh i'm not we're not trying
to replace them
today but tomorrow you know what i mean
like we want to get big
um before we really go after anything
they do that's core
but yeah no i'm on linkedin i'm on uh
i'm on i think i'm i'm on everything but
uh
twitter is where i spend most of my time
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this
again in the future yeah anytime